طرحه عربيه كبيره ان يصل منتخب عربي الى
هذا الدور من كاس العالم في ظل تنظيم ايضا
دوله عربيه لهذا المونديال بهذا المستوى
الجيد والرائع للغايه مباريات تقدم فيها
المنتخب المغربي بشكل كبير كان هناك مدربا
مغربيا واثق من شبابه استطاع ان يقدم خطه
رياضيه ناجحه للغايه اهلاته للفوز على
بلجيكا في انتصار لم يكن سهلا ايضا انتصر
على اسبانيا في مباراه صعبه للغايه ثم
انتصر اليوم على البرتغال كان يمتلك
تكتلاند دفاعيا من المنتخب المغربي تميز
به للغايه منذ بدايه هذه همم المباريات
لتحليلات الرياضيه همم عديده كانت تشير
الى ان هناك نقاط رائعه يتميز بها المنتخب
المغربي هو قادر على الدفاع بشكل جيد
ولديه حارس مرمى محترف همم للغايه لديه
خبره ومحترف في اشبيليه هو شاب وهو بونو
ولكنه يمتلك من القدرات والخبرات الكثير
كان هو العنوان الرئيسي في مباراه اسبانيا
حينما نجح في صد كل ضربات الجزاء
الترجيحيه ل اا اسبانيا ثم تميز اليوم
ايضا في سد العديد من ايضا الاهداف التي
كان يحاول بها البرتغال اختراق مرمى بونو
لكن البرتغال لم تنجح وتقدمه بالفعل
المنتخب المغربي في مباراه كان العرب في
كل مكان في المنطقه العربيه والافريقيه
يتابعونها والمشاعر والدعاء كان هو
العنوان
هذه هي صور للاحتفالات العالم المغربيه
بالطبع يتصدر
ترفع الاعلام المغربيه الان في العديد من
العواصم العربيه وبالطبع في العديد من
المدن المغربيه انتصار كبير لهذا المنتخب
هذا هو مونديال المفاجات كما يوصف الان
هناك مفاجات وهناك تاريخ جديد
ربما كان هناك بعض الفرق الافريقيه التي
وصلت الى مستويات متقدمه في المونديال
الكاميرون كاسينغال كه همم ايضا غنى ولكن
المنتخب المغربي هو اول منتخب عربي
وافريقي يصل الى المربع الذهبي لكاس
العالم والجميع ينتظر ويتابع المباراه
الصعبه
الخياليه للغايه ما بين
انجلترا وفرنسا حيث سيلتقي المنتخبين بعد
قليل في مباراه لم يكن بيتوقع ان تكون
هناك مباراه في النصف النهائي بين فريقين
بحجم فرنسا وانجلترا الفائز من هذه
المباراه سيلتقي المغرب ايضا ويظل الامل
ويظل الطمور وتظل الدعوات الصادقه وااا
الرغبات والامال والطموحات في قلوب كل
العرب وكل المغاربه للوصول الى الدور
النهائي
هذه مشاعر المغاربه هذه مشاعر العرب هذه
هي الفرحه
ههه
[تصفيق]